you don't need to be bulletproof to be a
superhero black women have always had
superpowers turning pain into progress
I'm doesn't need a hero it means a queen
I want to bring miracles to Harlem all
this could be yours I can be the mother
you always wanted me to be that's where
our money really comes from it's time to
let the ghosts of the past die I almost
burned our face me love flesh like
movies like a game of chess yes
everything that belongs man should be my
master will scorch Harlem to get to her
oh we can only handle one devil at a
time I've done cleaner works
[Music]
no you you can't be trusted
okay just doing our dirty work for us
my dark chocolate Boy Scout of course
you're going to save me she won't stop
me out there
because without me god help harlem god
help us all
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Luke Cage footage to break
down and a brand new character
nightshade from the Luke Cage comics we
also got a whole bunch of daredevil iron
fists and stuff for the rest of the year
to talk about so I'll talk about Luke
Cage first then I'll talk about all
about other stuff so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
all of this Luke Cage iron fist Heroes
for Hire stuff is gonna be dropping next
week so they do a pretty good job of the
trailer of letting you know why it's so
important that Luke Cage gets help from
Iron Fist in this to devil's Harlem
can't handle two devils at the same time
there's like a brief moment where they
make you think that he might be teaming
up with Mariah and she gives him that
dark chocolate Boy Scout speech it's a
great speech it's totally hilarious in a
really twisted way but we do find out
what's going on with nightshade and
Mariah during the season so he's
basically just coming in to take all of
Harlem for himself so it sounds like he
goes for Mariah first and then Luke Cage
sees this war erupting so obviously he
tries to step in and that might be where
he starts going up against Bushmaster
because most of what we've seen so far
it's just Luke Cage getting his ass beat
because he doesn't know martial arts in
Bushmaster is about as powerful as he is
so there's a couple really cool moments
that show you Bushmaster using his
abilities like he dodges some of shades
bullets later in the trailer you do see
shades doing what it seems like bowing
down to him but I think it's a bit of a
misdirect because pretty much the entire
trailer is shades and Mariah just
walking around Harlem together burning
people alive I'm done playing nice as if
she was playing nice before but
nightshade is the brand-new character
that they debut in this as Mariah's
protege so that's the way the series is
using her but in the comics she's a Luke
Cage villain that gives off this
pheromone that gives her the ability to
control animals so maybe they'll have
some funny spin on that during the
series because they play it so
real-world like I don't actually expect
her to have special powers like mutants
don't exist inside the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yet pending any major Avengers
for changes or x-men IP additions but
she's also meant to be
this really smart character in the
comics - that earned her doctorate while
she was in prison
so for the most part she's just meant to
be this really resourceful villain but
obviously she's super hot
so you can see why they would use her in
the trailer this way where like mariah
is giving her that big speech about how
Harlem doesn't need a superhero like
Luke Cage she's a superhero there's
nothing worse than a villain that thinks
they're the hero but they are making you
wonder about which of these new villains
bushmaster or Mariah is the worse of the
two because there's that very prominent
scene we're bushmaster burns her
building down and Luke Cage saves her
the other really new thing here too is
him talking to what looks like just
another power and Harlem this might just
be other people that are super rich that
are involved in whatever this giant war
with Bushmaster that's going on but if
you haven't seen it they dropped a whole
bunch of other footage a little while
ago of misty Knight and Colleen wing
just being the [ __ ] out of dudes in a
bar they're gonna be piling around
during the season and then obviously
there's all the Iron Fist stuff which
for some reason they haven't put in any
of the trailers either they're terrified
that people won't watch it because they
see that Iron Fist is in it and they
don't understand how Heroes for Hire
works from the comics or they do really
badass stuff and they just don't want to
give it away we've seen all that behind
the scenes stuff I've talked about it in
previous trailer videos but most of you
have also probably noticed that misty
Nights arm has Rand on it instead of
stark tech so in the comics misty Knight
has a very notable bionic arm it's made
by Tony Stark but in the world of the
Netflix shows because Danny Rand is sort
of the Tony Stark rich guy of this
universe he's the one that provides all
that stuff she doesn't have the arm in
this bar fight with Colleen wing and
these other dudes so maybe this is
around the time that they enter the
series and then while they're around she
gets the bionic arm like calling weak is
like Danny could probably help you with
that
then she gets the arm then she goes off
with Luke Cage and starts beating
people's asses I didn't mention this in
the other videos but Rosario Dawson's
Claire temple obviously a part of the
series she said that she's probably
gonna be done with Marvel Netflix after
this round of seasons so Luke Cage gets
a season three and I think it probably
will because Netflix really likes Luke
Cage she might not come back but that's
just her speculating and they also said
that they might not do another defenders
round Jeff
was talking about all the other series
that are premiering this year people
asked him about defenders season 2 and
he said that's up to Netflix we've
talked about it but it sounds like right
now there are not plans to do another
defenders team up they'll just do
crossovers like they're doing during
Luke Cage season 2 where you have iron
fist and they do heroes for hire which i
think is fine as long as they let things
bleed over into other series and grow
because eventually kingpin is gonna have
to take over all crime in New York City
right now they're still sort of
separated by boroughs like kingpin very
Manhattan type of villain
Mariah very Harlem type of villain but
here's the big thing - like this is the
big surprise so Jeff lobe revealed that
not only is daredevil season 3 also
gonna premiere this year but he also
said that iron fist season two is gonna
premiere this year - so because they
just finished iron fist season 2 I think
we're gonna see daredevil like maybe
September and then a couple months after
that right before the end of the year
that's when they'll drop iron fist
season 2 immortal weapons so if you
haven't seen any of the iron fist behind
the scenes is basically then doing more
immortal weapons Davos is coming back
he'll be one of the main villains if not
the main villain of season 2 there's
still a lot that we don't know about
season 2 but in the comics he's still
serpent he becomes the immortal weapon
of one of the other capital cities of
heaven so remember Kunlun disappeared at
the end of season 1 season 2 will
probably be them dealing with where it
went
maybe they'll deal with the mythology of
the celestial clock because they're very
logical comic book ways to explain why
you would not be able to access Kunlun
from Earth
but as I've said before I'm really
hoping that they tease a little bit of
daredevil season 3 at the end of Luke
Cage like they've done in the past but
they might wait till comic-con because
that's about a month away it's gonna be
the third week in July so we'll see just
keep your eyes peeled for potential
daredevil season 3 teasers in the next
couple of weeks
what'll happen later today is I'll post
my non-spoilery Incredibles 2 review
there's a lot of big movies that are
dropping in the next couple of weeks so
I'll explain the schedule when I post
that Incredibles video so that should be
up in the next couple of hours but while
you wait for everything click here to
rewatch all that spider-man ps4 sinister
6 footage and click here for that Kevin
Feige Avenger
for teaser we also might be getting
Avengers for stuff this week too
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight